die studentenvertretung der humboldt
universität zu berlin sucht einen
ansprechpartner für menschen die sich
diskriminiert
fühlen und das würde dann so aussehen
wir schauen mal rein wir bitten daher
weiße menschen von einer bewerbung
abzusehen
ja und damit herzlich willkommen claus
strunz in unserem studio r schüttelt
dann müssen dem klaus gar keine frage
stellen
unfassbar klaus wassermann sagen halte
das beste was man sagen kann es sind
halt studenten aber da liegt auch gleich
das problem es scheint sich ein
komplettes umdenken in der art wie man
sich gegenseitig betrachtet und
zusammenleben will gerade vor unser
aller augen zu vollziehen wie kommt man
um gottes willen auf die idee zu
schreiben dass sich weiße menschen auf
eine stelle nicht bewerben können und es
so zu begründen weil ihnen die erfahrung
fehlt um mit denen um die es da geht
also menschen die nach deutschland
gekommen sind die offensichtlich in
deutschland studieren die eine andere
hautfarbe haben wir einen anderen
kulturellen background haben und sich
vielleicht diskriminierungen gegenüber
sehen zu helfen das können also weise
nicht das können nur personals of color
oder als schwarze positionierte menschen
so was gefährliches verrücktes etwas in
unruhe bringen das habe ich sehr lange
nicht gesehen ist sein ein höhepunkt
oder besser gesagt tiefpunkt dieser
gesamten vogue ideologie haben die sich
dazu schon geäußert gibt es in dem
statement zu also die diese beschreibung
zurückgezogen wir müssen sie wir müssen
sie glaube ich in einen statement
zwingend einen noch keins wir müssen
einfach noch mal lasst es uns einmal
weil es so schmerzhaft und weil es
wehtut lasst es uns einmal umdrehen wir
stellen uns einmal vor es gäbe eine
stellenausschreibung und der drin steht
wir bitten schwarze menschen davon
abzusehen sich darüber wir bitten oder
fordern auf juden davon abzusehen sich
zu bewerben wir bitten fordern auf uns
wäre es recht oder wir sagen euch gleich
ihr werdet keine chance haben wenn ihr
muslime seit oder araber oder oder oder
oder es würde das land in flammen stehen
und zwar zu recht gelb einen riesen
protest hier ist es eine ganz klassische
umgekehrte diskriminierung weißen
gegenüber und es ist bereits akzeptiert
in einer bestimmten community in einer
bestimmten gesellschaftsgruppe die weit
über die unis hinaus strahlt das ist
besorgniserregend dass dürfen auf keinen
fall zulassen
also ich finde also ich warte gespannt
auf dieses segment weil ich glaube auch
es wird sicherlich proteste geben nicht
in dieser form wie wir es vielleicht
anders herum erwartet hätten aber das
ist ja so ein generelles problem müssen
wir uns da jetzt mehr müssen jetzt die
weißen sich dagegen mehr auflehnen oder
das ist das maximal perfide daran wenn
sich weiße jetzt zu wort melden so wie
ich jetzt weiß ich weiß ich doch schon
was gleich passieren wird ich werde
sozusagen der alte weise mann sein der
selber wahrscheinlich rassistische
gedanken in sich trägt sonst könnte er
diese meinung nicht vertreten das genaue
gegenteil ist der fall denn diese
stellenausschreibung diese formulierung
ist in sich rassistisch sie grenzt ja
weiße aus mit einer absolut unhaltbaren
begründung und ich gehe sogar noch eins
weiter wenn ich jetzt jüdischen glaubens
wäre und mich diskriminierung mein leben
begleitete in deutschland dann dürfte
ich dort nicht arbeiten denn ich bin
dann ja keine person of color und auch
nicht als schwarzer positioniert sondern
weiß ein weißer mensch was ist das für
eine formulierung ein weißer mit wenn
ich ein osteuropäer bin der hier nach
deutschland gekommen ist und der am
arbeitsplatz oder in der straßenbahn
oder im supermarkt sozusagen
diskriminierung ausgesetzt ist dürfte
ich mich dort nicht bewerben obwohl ich
doch diese erfahrung habe und was ist
das überhaupt für eine kranke idee zu
sagen man braucht dieses eigener
erfahrung also man braucht quasi den die
erfahrung um entsprechende ratschläge
geben zu können wir stellen uns noch mal
was anderes vor stellt euch mal vor ein
einzelhandels laden oder eine
kaufhaus-kette würde einer
stellenausschreibung machen unserer
erfahrung nach sind weiße die besseren
verkäufer die machen mehr umsatz deshalb
bitten wir schwarze und muslime sich
nicht zu bewerben was war da los und ich
möchte dass es in diese richtung genau
so los ist ich möchte dass wir darüber
diskutieren jetzt kann man sagen das ist
so ein fitzelchen an der berliner uni
das ist vielmehr das ist der anfang
eines umgekehrten rassismus den nicht
zulassen dürfen
[Musik]